y
i
es decir
el presidente de eeuu joe biden se
reunió con los líderes de la unión
europea con el objetivo de reavivar las
relaciones con el bloque el encuentro se
produce después de su primera cumbre con
la otan en la que la alianza atlántica
endureció su tono contra china y previo
a su encuentro con el presidente ruso
vladimir putin en miércoles en ginebra
suiza tenemos reporte desde bruselas
eeuu se acerca a los seiscientos mil
muertos por joven 19 consolidándose como
la nación más afectada por el virus a
nivel global el congreso rindió homenaje
a las víctimas y el presidente de joe
biden insistió en la importancia de
vacunarse cuando las dosis aplicadas ya
superan los 310 millones
y sigue la incertidumbre en perú ante
los resultados de la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales del pasado
6 de junio la candidata derechista keiko
fujimori anunció que ha presentado una
serie de nulidades
mientras las rondas campesinas
anunciaron que seguirán llegando a lima
para defender la victoria del
izquierdista pedro castillo
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí entradas 24
heridos de nuevo yo soy liliana valencia
iniciamos en bruselas porque el
presidente de eeuu joe biden se reúne
hoy por primera vez con los líderes de
la unión europea después de su primera
cumbre con la otan ayer el objetivo del
encuentro es reactivar los lazos
transatlánticos en temas como la lucha
contra el cob y 19 acuerdos comerciales
y cambio climático el encuentro se
produce previo a su reunión con el
presidente ruso vladimir putin este
miércoles en ginebra suiza realmente
hablamos con nuestra corresponsal en
bruselas esther herrera quien nos
entregó detalles de esta información
pues joe biden el presidente de eeuu si
está en el edificio de la sede del
consejo europeo donde se reúne ahora
mismo en estos momentos con el
presidente del consejo sales michelle y
la presenta la comisión europea ursula
von der leyen como comentabas hay
bastantes temas candentes como por
ejemplo este acuerdo comercial que
permitiría que no se apliquen aranceles
debido a la disputa entre airbús y boing
a partir de ahora no se aplicarán más
aranceles en los próximos cinco años
después de que hubiese una tregua de
estos seis meses y que ahora mismo
acababa este acuerdo es de gran
importancia ya que las dos potencias
llevaban casi veinte años con esta
disputa por otra parte están otras
cuestiones como por ejemplo la lucha por
la 19a la unión europea preocupa mucho
que eeuu hasta ahora no exportará
vacunas y que ahora mismo por fin lo
haya decidido también está la cuestión
del cambio climático en que ambas
potencias tienen un buen entendimiento y
por supuesto rusia este auge de las
tensiones en los últimos meses
también estará encima de la mesa pero en
cualquier caso los líderes europeos
apoyan fuertemente en la reunión que
mantendrán ryder y vladimir putin mañana
en ginebra sin duda esta reunión sirve
sobre todo para limar las asperezas
entre eeuu y la unión europea
tras participar en esta cumbre joe biden
continuará con su gira europea mañana 16
de junio se prevé que se reúna con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin en ginebra-
las relaciones entre rusia y eeuu nunca
han sido fáciles cuando putin llegó al
kremlin la casa blanca lo vio como un
potencial aliado aunque esas sensaciones
fueron desvaneciéndose en este reporte
les contamos los lazos entre moscú y
washington durante la era pública
[Música]
joven y aparentemente moderno
inicialmente vladimir putin le pareció
eeuu su nombre con el que podían hacer
negocios
george bush- lo recibió en su rancho de
texas con halagos hospitalidad y un
viaje de pesca en maine pero la
camaradería desapareció cuando estados
unidos invadió irak y expulsó un aliado
de moscú
saddam hussein después de que la guerra
entre rusia y georgia tensar aún más las
relaciones la administración obama
intentó un reinicio en 2019
erróneamente restablecerse tradujo como
sobrecarga y eso fue lo que le sucedió
al vínculo cuando estalló el conflicto
con ucrania en 2014 al igual que con
irak
rusia percibió que eeuu su persigue una
agenda de cambio de régimen en todo el
mundo
los lazos se deterioraron todavía más
cuando el kremlin fue acusan de
interferir a favor de donald trump en
las elecciones presidenciales de 2016
algo nuestro objetivo sigue siendo
enviar un mensaje a rusia ya otros no
nos hagan esto porque podemos hacer las
cosas a ustedes because we can de
station
en las conmemoraciones del día de las
miradas de obama y putin parecían decir
exactamente eso sabemos lo que estás
haciendo y nosotros también la trama
rusa arrojó una larga sombra sobre la
presidencia de trump él parecía ansioso
por complacer a putin en la cumbre de
helsinki en 2018 pero el mandatario ruso
mantuvo la distancia y arrojo esta
famosa frase a mujer a quien debes
creerle a quien no debes creerle
no puedes creerle a nadie nunca
las elecciones de 2016 no fueron el
único tema que causó revuelo en marzo
las agencias de inteligencia
estadounidenses afirmaron que rusia
intentó debilitar a joe biden en las
elecciones de 2020 esa acusación podría
no molestar a putin después de todo ha
sobrevivido a cuatro presidentes de eeuu
y es que ese lunes tuvo lugar en
bruselas bélgica la cumbre de la
organización del tratado atlántico norte
otan con la participación del presidente
de eeuu joe biden por primera vez
marcando el fin de cuatro años de
tensiones con el ex presidente de trump
que llegó a calificar de obsoleta la
alianza la relaciones con china y rúsia
la ciberseguridad y el retiro de las
tropas de afganistán para los
principales temas de la agenda
una nueva era para la otan tras cuatro
años de tensiones con donald trump en la
primera cumbre de la alianza con joe
biden a bordo los aliados elevaron su
tono contra china y rúsia a los que
calificaron de autoritarios training in
france la creciente influencia de china
y las políticas internacionales
presentan desafíos para la seguridad de
la alianza de la otan
don't know what it's in action committee
mans
pedimos a china que respete sus
compromisos internacionales y actúe
responsablemente incluso en los dominios
espacial cibernético marítimo de acuerdo
con su papel como gran potencia en
chipping with these roads center por
hayden quien promete fortalecer la otan
instó antes del evento a plantar cara
china y a su creciente poderío militar
mientras que concluyó que rusia continúa
siendo el enemigo número uno del bloque
[Música]
compartir con nuestros aliados lo que le
transmitirá el presidente putin que no
estoy buscando un conflicto con rusia
pero que responderemos si rusia continúa
con sus activos
y no dejaremos de defender la alianza
transatlántica o de ponernos de pie por
los valores democráticos habituales los
aliados también expresaron su necesidad
de hacer frente a los ataques
cibernéticos procedentes principalmente
desde territorio ruso de igual forma
acordaron pautar un protocolo de retiro
de sus tropas en afganistán y fijar una
hoja de ruta contra el cambio climático
cambiamos de información porque eeuu se
acerca a los 600 mil muertos por kobe 19
este lunes la cifra llegó a 599 mil 965
fallecidos según cifras de la
universidad johns hopkins líderes del
congreso rindieron homenaje a los
fallecidos y el presidente joe biden
aprovechó la oportunidad para insistir a
sus ciudadanos en la importancia de
vacunarse ya son más de 310 millones de
dosis administradas
un homenaje a las casi 600 mil víctimas
mortales que deja el kobe 19 en eeuu
desde el inicio de la pandemia
un grupo de líderes del congreso
estadounidense se reunió las afueras del
capitolio para recordarlos y honrarlos
con un minuto de silencio la cifra total
de muertos por el virus en el país es
igual a la cantidad de estadounidenses
que murieron de cáncer en 2019 y mucho
mayor al número de habitantes de
ciudades como miami atlanta durante su
visita a europa el presidente joe biden
reconoció este hito sombrío y siguió
instando a los estadounidenses a
vacunarse contra el kobe 19 a pesar de
que el número de muertes diarias ha
disminuido drásticamente y en medio del
escepticismo de un gran número de
ciudadanos
por eso les sigo diciendo a eeuu si no
se han vacunado vacunen se vacunen se lo
antes posible
tenemos muchas vacunas en muchos sitios
tenemos más trabajo por hacer para
vencer este virus y ahora no es el
momento de bajar la guardia así que por
favor vacunarse ya hemos tenido
suficiente dolor de acuerdo con el
centro para el control y prevención de
enfermedades el 43 7% del total de la
población ha sido completamente
inoculada mientras que el 52% ha
recibido al menos
una dosis la alta reserva de vacunas en
eeuu ha llevado a ciudadanos de países
de américa latina a visitar el país para
aplicársela la mayoría de las
restricciones se han levantado en toda
la unión americana entre ellas el uso
obligatorio de mascarillas y se espera
que eeuu vuelva a la normalidad para el
4 de julio el día de su independencia
una fecha para la cual el país comenzará
a independizarse del virus según lo
prometido por el mismo baile vamos con
más información relacionada con el coi
19 aquí en france 24
colombia se acerca a los 100.000
fallecidos por coronavirus y sigue
reportando altas cifras diarias de
muertes y contagios en las últimas 24
horas la cifra de muertes fue de 588 por
un total de 96 mil 366 fallecidos desde
el inicio de la pandemia de sérpico del
joven 19 nueva tregua en el país
cafetero con más de 20.000 casos diarios
confirmados desde hace varias semanas y
con las unidades de cuidados intensivos
trabajando casi al 100% de su capacidad
francia inició la vacunación para
adolescentes de 12 años en adelante pero
únicamente con la fórmula de facer y
bayón tech y con la autorización de
ambos padres a partir de hoy unos 3.5
millones de jóvenes podrán recibir la
dosis con el objetivo de limitar al
máximo la circulación del virus en el
país gana
de tanto italia avanza un paso más hacia
la reapertura con el levantamiento del
toque de queda después de medianoche por
primera vez en más de siete meses en la
mayoría de las regiones del país
seis regiones más se sumaron a la
denominada zona blanca que representa
bajo riesgo de contagio por kobe 19
vamos ahora con noticias de américa
latina' porque en perú sigue sin
proclamarse oficialmente quién es el
ganador de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales del pasado 6
de junio entre el candidato de izquierda
pedro castillo y la derechista keiko
fujimori con el 100% de las actas
procesadas la diferencia entre ambos
candidatos es mínima y le da la ventaja
a castillo integrantes de las rondas
campesinas aseguraron que seguirán
llegando a lima para defender la
victoria del docente la candidata
fujimori anunció que respuesta su equipo
legal para auditar lo que ella insiste
sin pruebas serían irregularidades en el
proceso electoral después de haber
recibido múltiples denuncias por
acciones realizadas por miembros de perú
libre para alterar los resultados de
esta elección decidimos presentar una
serie de nulidades haciendo uso de
nuestro legítimo derecho de tener un
proceso limpio y transparente en los
últimos días una serie de marchas y
contramarchas en las decisiones del
jurado nacional de elecciones nos han
generado una
funda preocupación porque alguna de sus
decisiones vulneran directamente nuestro
derecho a la revisión de estas
irregularidades hoy se reúne el consejo
permanente de la organización de estados
americanos oea con el objetivo de
analizar la situación en nicaragua donde
el gobierno de daniel ortega ha detenido
al menos 13 líderes opositores cuatro de
ellos aspirantes a las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo 7 de
noviembre y las cuales ortega busca un
cuarto mandato consecutivo durante el
encuentro se votará una resolución el
cuyo objetivo sería instar al mandatario
a revertir las detenciones para avistar
por amar israel la denominada marcha de
las banderas en la cual grupos de
extrema derecha se tomarán las calles de
la disputada jerusalén del este la
manifestación podría generar nuevas
tensiones con los palestinos quienes la
consideran como una provocación esto
justo cuando el nuevo gobierno de nafta
live net entra en funciones sin benjamín
netanyahu por primera vez en 12 años la
coalición de gobierno debe ponerse de
acuerdo en temas clave si quiere evitar
unas nuevas elecciones
los unió el objetivo de deshacerse de
netanyahu ahora que ya no está
empieza el trabajo real de encontrar
puntos en común el primer reto de la
nueva coalición será aprobar un nuevo
presupuesto en sus primeros 100 días si
no alcanzan un acuerdo la que knesset el
parlamento israelí se disolverá y el
país deberá ir a elecciones una vez más
el hombre al frente del ministerio de
finanzas es avigdor liberman y no se le
conoce precisamente por ser una voz de
calma
se espera que la coalición se centre en
la recuperación económica del país tras
la pandemia de coronavirus especialmente
porque es una de las cuestiones en la
que todos los partidos pueden ponerse de
acuerdo israel tiene una de las campañas
de vacunación más avanzadas del mundo
ahora los parlamentarios quieren
traducir este éxito en crecimiento
económico
la nueva coalición es la más diversa de
la historia de israel compartidos de
derecha e izquierda y partidos árabes
eso dificulta encontrar una voz común
para negociar el conflicto palestino el
mismo benet se opone abiertamente a la
solución de dos estados su partido ya
mina apoya la construcción de colonias
israelíes en los territorios palestinos
ocupados así que por ahora es improbable
que la política israelí sobre el
conflicto palestino cambie así
finalizamos porque ustedes pueden
continuar con más temprano 24 puntos
como para emplear la información de
américa del día y el mundo nos vemos más
adelante
[Música]